mais moi je viens parce que je suis sûr
qu'à un obélisque dans le slip quoi les
suivis on va tout jouer au baba phone
c'est parti c'est le ba ba
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les crocs il y a des touches
téléphone un tour à tour vous allez
choisir un numéro et derrière chaque
numéro se cache un gage ou un truc sympa
bernard montiel joly c'est quelqu'un
alors j'ai choisi le 2 passes et 20
secondes en mode vibreur
donc vous voyez ça je pense qu'en fait
on à patrick nokia qui est là et vous
allez passer vingt secondes en mode
vibreur de danse vous allez voir il
levait vous devez vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
oui
le numéro 7 numéros solide anime le
numéro 7
alors vous avez traité tout une en mai
nord
m
réputé tout de suite en direct et vous
allez rien dire je suis chaud comme une
baraque à frites d'accord hashtag #rugby
ça le hashtag #rugby année mois à
l'effacer après chef non non pas du tout
à coup on est passé bien voulu garder sa
malade ou quoi
quand vous regardez mais ça vous
correspond tout à fait arrêté à huit
tasses et vous l'avez elle a vu un bon
truc à bâle à huit a fait une
déclaration d'amour enflammées une
personne de votre répertoire
je vais choisir la personne de mémoire
il n'y a pas de répertoire d'abba de
répertoire aurait peur tout commence à
avoir avoué dans les sms ne régit voir
le dernier rappel bas s'il vous plaît
donnez moi les miens mais là c'est quoi
ce téléphone là oui je savais que ça
allait vous énervez dégueulasse donnez
moi votre portable à vous ça vous suis
là et bien il n'a plus quelqu'un de
votre répertoire avec qui j'ai
communiqué c'est bien jean challans
huawei par malema pierre jean salençon
bakar jean salençon c'est parfait ce qui
fait je te kiffe
je voulais toi absolument pierre-jean ça
va tu vas bien qu'ils seraient pas
libres ce soir perdant mais moi je viens
parce que je suis sûr qu'à un obélisque
dans le slip
[Applaudissements]
oui oui
merci bien comprendre il ajouté ah ouais
bah sport avec bouffe ras le cul des
deux alors je vais prendre l'a4
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je
la commande batterie m'a marqué à 6,6
alors la joue là c'est 30% qui 30% ses
traits rouges qui blessent en ce moment
je te le jure
c'est bon c'est 30% de la rue crémazie
bagram voilà c'est pas grave bravo à
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]